Olha só, você deixaria um robô cuidar do
seu pai e da sua mãe com demência? Pois
é, no Japão isso já está acontecendo.
Olha só o cenário. Quase 30% da
população japonesa tem mais de 65 anos e
os casos de demência explodiram. Em
2024, mais de 18.000 idosos apareceram
depois de sair de casa e quase 500 foram
encontrados mortos. E qual foi a solução
que eles encontraram? Tecnologia,
rastreadores com GPS em pulseiras que
avisam automaticamente quando o idoso
sai de uma área segura. inteligência
artificial que analisa a postura e o
jeito de caminhar para detectar sinais
precoces de demência e robôs cuidadores
que ajudam nas tarefas do dia a dia,
monitoram o sono, lembram horário de
remédio e até conversam para diminuir a
solidão. Agora veja bem, como médico eu
entendo o apelo. Falta cuidadores, os
custos são astronômicos e a tecnologia
pode sim dar mais autonomia e segurança,
mas a conexão humana, o toque, o olhar,
isso nenhum robô substitui. A própria
matéria reconhece que essas máquinas
devem complementar o cuidado e nunca
substituir. E você, o que que você acha?
Se isso chegasse na sua família, você
aceitaria um robô ajudando em casa ou
sentiria que passa do limite? Me conta
aqui nos comentários.